what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
a ton of spider-man news has happened
over the last few days and at this point
it's all getting
pretty official marvel has been trying
so hard to keep the spider-verse in no
way home a secret but at this point in
time with the actors themselves
confirming that they'll be in the film
and confirming the multiverse
marvel is having a pretty hard time of
keeping this in the shadows
but good for them for trying so we have
the confirmation of the multiverse
confirmation of not one but two villains
one of which is rumored to be the main
villain and
we have a plot leak from somebody who
has proved accurate in his leaks before
and i'm gonna break it all down and a
big thank you to squarespace for
sponsoring today's video
from websites to online stores to
marketing tools squarespace can help you
build a beautiful
online presence more in them in a bit
and be sure to check out my giveaway in
the description down below
so if you have not heard alfred molina
who of course played dr
octavius and spider-man 2 the original
one with toby maguire has
publicly come out and stated that he is
indeed
going to be in spider-man no way home
and not only did he come out
stating that he's going to be in the
film he said that it's going to be the
same
character from the same sam raimi
universe in fact he
said that his story is going to pick up
again right where it left off
at the end of spider-man 2 where he's
sinking into the ocean
which is very interesting because we
technically didn't see him
die we assumed so way back then in 2004
but that was before the multiverse was
really a thing now anybody can kind of
stay alive
and that's actually what alfred molina
said the director told him
he said he asked john watts the director
how he's going to come back
if he died in which john watts replied
in this universe
no one really dies which is true we now
have time travel and the multiverse
there's ways to get around it
then the article specifically says in
their early conversations alfred molina
said that john watts told him that the
movie will pick up
doc ock's story from that moment in the
river which in a franchise that includes
multiverses
time travel and diverging timeline seems
plausible enough so it sounds like
they're going to take
alfred molina right before he dies at
the end of spider-man 2
and take him into a different universe
our universe and that's how he becomes
one of the villains or perhaps even
maybe somewhat of a hero
in no way home and the same probably
goes for jamie foxx's electro as well
now as i mentioned we have a spider-man
no way home plot league today
and this is actually really cool because
this leak is coming from somebody who
leaked the information about the secret
cameo that was
in the falcon and the winter soldier
episode 5. this person posted that the
cameo was going to be
julia louise dreyfus way before the
episode premiered so that means they
actually do know a thing or two about
what's going on behind the scenes and
now they have a plot leak for us
so let's begin the plot leak says the
movie starts off where far from home
ended and
there is a time skip peter is in court
and there is a lot going on
he is trying to prove his innocence
doctor strange calls out that there is
something going on
and the multiverse is breaking villains
are going around from other worlds into
others
kind of jumping world to world doctor
strange is trying to capture them
and put them in a special made prison by
him the villains somehow escape
because tom holland's peter parker
messes with some stuff
probably in the sanctum sanctorum toby
maguire's peter parker and
andrew garfield's peter parker are in
the second and third act of the movie
and the leaker states that how they met
or how they came into tom holland's
world is unknown to him
but both toby maguire's peter parker and
andrew garfield's peter parker help out
tom holland's peter parker and dr
strange in rounding up the villains in
their world the leaker says there are
scenes
in the movie with just tobey maguire and
andrew garfield
alone so it's not just going to be team
up scenes according to this leaker we're
actually going to get some one-on-one
time with the previous spider-man
it goes on to say that the movie's final
act is on the statue of liberty that now
looks like a big captain america with
the shield
and this is actually something that
we've seen a very recent leaked
set photo for so this part is confirmed
to be true
now why is the statue of liberty dressed
like the new captain america well that's
because
spider-man no way home picks up right
after the events of spider-man far from
home and we know that spider-man far
from home takes place
six months after avengers in-game and so
does the falcon and the winter soldier
so it is possible that this is all
happening right when john walker is
named the new
captain america to me this makes the
most sense because why else would they
decorate the statue of liberty
like captain america unless they were
celebrating captain america
and the announcement of a new captain
america we've already seen has been
greeted with
parades marching bands and the new
captain america is supposed to be a
symbol of hope
to america and the world so they most
likely dressed up the statue of liberty
to commemorate
this that's what makes the most sense to
me but who knows it goes on to say that
all of the villains are there with tom
holland spider-man toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man
stark's arc reactor is present in the
scene and every villain is trying to get
their hands on it for something the
leaker says that based on what they saw
that part was not very clear
but all of the villains go on to be
defeated and are put back in the prison
of dr
strange all of them except willem
dafoe's
green goblin but they go on to say that
the green goblin goes on to kill
somebody major
the leaker is not sure who this person
is but tom holland's peter parker was
crying
and enraged he tries to kill the green
goblin but wasn't successful in doing so
in the end
the movie ends with peter parker
finishing high school and it's not clear
on what happens to toby maguire and
andrew garfield spider-man
and that's it for the plot leak and
that's actually quite a bit of
information coming from somebody who has
already been proven as
a good legitimate source so still a lot
to talk about including who the main
villain is rumored to be and we'll talk
about that but first thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring today's video
and again big thank you to squarespace
for sponsoring this video
squarespace is an all-in-one platform to
help you
build an online presence and run your
business you can create a beautiful
website with squarespace and that
includes online stores and squarespace
makes it easy with their online
marketing tools and analytics
if you were like how i was wanting to
build a website but didn't know how
squarespace is for you as they offer
custom templates this makes it
incredibly easy to build the website
that you want and you can embed videos
on your site like i do
and you can also link your social media
accounts to the website helping drive
traffic to those as well
if you are looking to seamlessly build a
website or an online store head over to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
wonder to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
now there have been a few reports
talking about norman osborne's green
goblin returning for spider-man no way
home
this plot leak actually isn't the first
time that we've heard this
however this plot leak does back it up
and recently
a twitter account that has been right
about some previous leaks in the past
has been stating that willem dafoe's
green goblin is indeed the main villain
of spider-man no way home now we did
indeed see green goblin
die in the very first spider-man but
like john watts said
nobody's really dead in this universe
they could very well grab him before he
dies or perhaps just like is happening
in the main mcu timeline the reality is
breaking in other timelines
after all we are getting jamie foxx's
electro in spider-man no way home
and it definitely looked like he died in
the amazing spider-man 2
although he could have been teleported
to a different universe obviously not
much is known about how everything is
going to happen and go down in
spider-man no way home but this plot
leak is a great start
hopefully it's all true like i said this
leaker was right about the falcon and
the winter soldier episode 5
cameo so they seem to be pretty legit so
at this point in time we know that jamie
foxx's electro is going to be returning
willem dafoe's green goblin is most
likely returning and alfred molino's
doctor octavius is going to be returning
as well and alfred molina in his
interview basically confirmed the
multiverse for us
and of course if i hear anything else
regarding spider-man no way home or any
other marvel news i'll get it out to you
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
be sure to let me know what you think
about this plot leak and alfred molina
confirming the multiverse let me know in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you